We can see in Amdahl's Law. Let's talk
about what it implies for our improvements. So our
Amdahl's Law says that Speedup is equal to
1 over 1 minus fraction enhanced, this is the
part of the program that we didn't enhance
and it just figures here, plus the fraction that
we did enhance. And that fraction became so much
faster because of the speed up on the path.
So now, let's compare two possible enhancements. This
is the first enhancement, this will be the
second enhancement. The first enhancement is giving us
a speedup of 20 which is an extremely
large speedup on 10% of execution time. Enhancement
2 is giving us a speedup of 1.6
on 80% of execution time. Using Amdahl's Law,
we can now compute, what is the overall
speedup resulting from these enhancements? Here, we have 1 over
unaffected is 90% of execution time. Affected is
0.1. And it's shorter by 20 times. You can compute
this, and get 1.105. Here, we get 1 over, the
unenhanced fraction is 0.2, the enhanced
fraction is 0.8 and we speed that up by the 1.6 factor and
we get 1.43. As you can see, it is usually better to have a smaller speedup on
most of your execution time, than a huge speedup on a very small part of it.
In fact, even if we have an infinite speedup on this 10% of execution
time, we would get 1 over unenhanced 0.9, enhanced 0.1 divided by
infinity, so it becomes 0. And we still get 1.111. Now, it is very, very
difficult to get huge speedups like this
on anything. And it's, of course, impossible
to get infinite speedups. So, what this means, is that if you put significant
effort to speedup something that is a small
part of the execution time you will still
not get a very large overall improvement. In
contrast, if you're affecting a large part of
execution time then even a reasonably small speedup
will still result in a similar speed up
overall. So the overall conclusion from this is
that Amdahl's Law tells us to make the
common case fast. Whatever spends the most of our
execution time is what should we be trying to
speedup. And we should not focus too much on
stuff that consumes very little of our execution time.